why has greta thunderberg had such an
impact on the world how did a swedish
school girl skipping a day of school to
sit outside our country's parliament go
on to address the un and be nominated
for the nobel peace prize
was it simply the right time or are
young women simply more appealing world
leaders in a world unenthusiastic about
its political leaders so let's discuss
this now and cece to you first of all
there are a lot of eco activists out
there so why do you think greta
thundberg has managed to end up with
such a large profile what's the secret
of her success do you think
yes thank you so much for having me um i
think what is so special about greta is
that she has two very unique qualities
the first one is that she has this thing
about not being afraid of being alone
and if you look at how in the past you
know her journey she was advocating for
climate change alone for a long time
before she was noticed and she couples
this with really uh this kind of second
quality which is um this strong sense of
purpose and this you know this scent
this pup of this purpose is so
passionate that she feels really so
strongly about that her
you know school uh strike for the
climate has really now grown into a
global movement she hasn't you know
inspired millions to take action and
demand action for climate change
and clearly a huge number of people
follow her and support her but also
richard she gets a lot of criticism as
well doesn't she let's just take a look
at what donald trump said about her he
said greta must work on her anger
management problem then go to a good
old-fashioned movie with a friend and
he's not alone she's sparked a bit of a
backlash from a number of people hasn't
she so she's not altogether popular why
do you think she attracts the criticism
i think anyone who is a successful
environmental campaigner attracts
criticism from people who do not like
environmental campaigning and she's been
spectacularly successful the biggest
kind of meteor that streaked across our
heavens uh probably the last decade or
so
it's kind of ironic really some of the
most vocal critics have been newspaper
columnists in in in the uk who tend to
be you know middle-aged men and uh of
course it shouldn't be an 18-year-old
swedish schoolgirl who's telling people
what to think it should be middle-aged
men writing for british newspapers
that's their job shortly
that's interesting but also cece what
about the question of whether or not
she's being listened to i mean she
obviously makes headlines but is she
having an impact i think she herself has
talked about the youth summit that's
going on in milan now saying
they don't listen to us emissions are
still rising the science doesn't lie is
she cutting through at all
i think she really is you know i think
the fact that she has managed to inspire
so many people to take action is the
fact that she is being listened to um
and the uh the government officials
there also have um
you know like opened up these
discussions for young people to
to bring in their voice there is
progress but um you know i think there
is more to be done um in order to bring
young people more young people
onto the table and have these
discussions
what do you think richard do you think
that these young climate activists are
being heard i mean there are concerns
amongst them that they're not being they
feel they haven't got the agency a lot
of them are too young to even vote but
but do you think that they are having an
impact
yes i think they're absolutely having an
impact and they are being heard and just
coming back to one of these the question
that you asked initially anna what makes
greta turnburg so successful one of the
key things about her and a lot of the
other young women around her is that
they are utterly authentic they don't
pretend to be scientists they don't
pretend to be you know interested in
going into government they are just
telling it as they see it and that's
massively appealing um of course with
every government there's a difference
there's a stage between accepting what
the science is and accepting what public
opinion is and then actually enacting
policy and that's the difficult bridge
and that's perhaps where they're not
quite having the impact that they would
want to have so richard briefly do you
think that cop 26
will take notice of what's been said at
the youth cop
yes i think it will take note of it
whether actually any of the because in
the end the decisions are made by
individual governments the decisions not
made by the by the un or some sort of
amorphous body like that so whether
enough individual governments uh take
note of this and of course all the other
warnings that are coming from science
and and change what they're doing that
is really the big question
cece very briefly do you agree with that
yes i i do